and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya the three muslims you have
your regulars here today alhamdulillah
today is going to be a very special
episode because we are predominantly
doing
q and a
so get started with the questions
inshaallah but how are you guys doing
today
how are you
done
what time is german where you guys are
at
i think it's 1 30
yeah it's 1 30 for me so
i got to be out here in
38 minutes
we got one in 10 minutes we got one in
one hour and then one in two hours
oh it's nice
is it still even
in two hours
no bro and in two hours it's definitely
gonna be awesome but what's weird is we
have one after us i don't even know if
that's valid
uh i mean there is one one math hub that
pushed like they push also back a little
bit
compared to the other so maybe it's it's
that muthub that the masjid follows but
i don't know my measure did the same
thing but it was like way too late it
was like maybe three three to three
thirty something like that um
[Music]
i had 24 viewers let's go we got some
questions in soon
but
before we do that
you know what just for this let me
change the uh
yeah i was about to say like you can't
really see it that well
i was going to say it looks really nice
honestly
honestly
looks it looks nice but you can't see
that well yeah at least on mobile
probably
yeah
that is much better
[Music]
m
[Music]
all right so this is end of your stream
all right
we're not gonna we're not gonna say
anything cringy at the end like hey guys
uh we'll see you next year you know
[Music]
okay
so two minutes in 24 viewers smash the
like button we got the first question
from brother syed
well you're always saying
that's a good question
that is
that's tough that was tough
i don't know what are the benefits that
you get from standing up just so the
viewers can understand you on a deeper
level
i mean it's a simple
answer that's answered with a question
was our body meant to be sitting or was
it meant to be moving
i agree
i agree
man it's like 6 30 where you all at
can't get over the fact that hell is
eternal um
okay well
first and foremost i just want to say
that this is a a moral thing which means
immediately it's subjective because
you'll have people that say hell should
be eternal uh that people some people
just don't deserve heaven no matter how
long they wait
um and you have people that you know are
probably a little softer to be
completely honest even i felt this at
some point in my life
um that's like why would it make sense
for them to be punished forever
um
and if you think about it in many ways
it makes sense so first and foremost
should someone like hitler ever enter
heaven ever
even after a billion years
because he
did a lot like a lot and we're not and
like you can't put a price on someone's
life like one life was one year or
something like that because every life
is priceless
allah says if you kill one person
innocent person it's as if you killed
all of mankind
imagine he he killed how many people six
six million
that's six million humanities that he
killed
does he ever deserve to go to jannah
come on
and at the same time allah
mentions in the quran that if they
were to stay on the earth
basically past their deaths forever they
would continue and they would never
accept
allah islam so on and so forth
so even if they were to be alive here
forever they do the same thing forever
and ever and ever
yeah
i was going to say too
like they have their entire lives
you know like
you could be doing everything wrong but
as long as you are sincere
and your repentance to allah like allah
knows best allah knows exactly what's
going on inside your heart
so like we could see someone and we
could say like oh this person man
they're such a bad person
but in reality in their heart
like allah knows exactly what they're
doing and what they're trying to do to
be better and they may be accepting to
gentlemen just because of that yeah yeah
exactly so
it kind of goes back to like i know
we're not talking about allah here we're
talking about heaven and hell
but um
i believe it was either allah said this
or was it the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
uh but it's like
no it was definitely allah
allah says uh
i am what my servant thinks of me
so if
you
think allah is just like
this tyrant type entity that's basically
punishing everyone and bringing them all
to hell
there's probably there's probably a
reason behind that and you know it's
it's something that's
that's like rooted deep inside your
psyche as a person
you know what i'm saying yeah
i agree bro
we'll watch ali hall's video about why
he always stands instead of sits that's
funny that's true man's always standing
not that he's not he's the golden
standard of
i don't know
body came again he's been sitting lately
i noticed that too but most of his
videos he's standing hey
in the past
yeah yeah i like that
and next question from
ks l or ksi i don't care that's too far
it's really haram to us in the music
again we're not scholars we're not going
to give fatwas but it's unequivocal to
me at least from my research that is
haram there's no more crew about it
the prophet saws said that
there will be people of my ummah that
that try to make permissible um silk
uh adultery fornication and music
musical instruments right um saying that
i saw some that there will be people
that try to make it halal or permissible
means that it's not right kind of like
when you look at
um a lot of people know that you know
when you when women go to do umrah um
when they're in
women can't cover their face
and people are like oh look that's
that's proof that women aren't supposed
to cover their face i would go farther
to say that that's proof that women
um have to cover their face that their
face is out of because they have to
cover it because they're not allowed to
cover it during that time like why is
that specifically mentioned you know
what i mean
it's weird though because i mean
music is such a wide category
like even a nasheed
with no instruments it's still
classified as music
yeah yeah so
there are two opinions
one is extremely extremely minority as
far as i know and they do say
or maybe even
but there is one opinion that says it's
not haram um
whether it's mukuru or halal i don't
know but they say it's not haram but
that's a minority opinion majority
opinion is that musical instruments
and this does not include the vocals and
singing and all of that is specifically
musical instruments and everything
except the arabic drum the the duff i
believe is what it's called um but the
fad were you were you saying that uh
like
is
that what you're saying so basically a
lot of people uh say that a woman just
wearing hijab is enough their face is
not outta
and when people talk about um when you
go to umrah right when women learn
um it's actually i don't know if you
know this but men and women were not
allowed to cover our faces so for women
they can't actually cover their face
right and a lot of people say hey look
that's proof that a woman's face is not
out
i would go as far as to say that a lot
of research i've done it shows that
that's proof that it is aura because if
you think about it why would there be a
specific prohibition for women not to
cover their face
if they weren't already supposed to
cover their face yeah
you say this yeah okay i see what you're
saying that's what you're saying um
on this point i i think that's also my
minority opinion that is
it is an opinion but i foreign it's
minority opinion the lies of the prophet
saws
she would show like only one eye
but that's
the wife of the prophet
salla so her standards i believe were
actually a lot uh higher than others and
that's why majority opinion
is everything except the hands and the
face must be covered uh but there is a
minority opinion this is
guys one more thing like there's a lot
of questions so if you send a super
chatter you remember guarantee answer
otherwise we're just going to try to go
through whatever ones we can inshaallah
welcome
to life
i was wondering how one can go about
restraining themselves from watching pmo
uh as well as committing zina of the
hand
okay we're going to be real uh discreet
with the terms though
i think i've said this so many times
but it's it's honestly changing your
day-to-day
habits
and your day-to-day routine your
lifestyle
because
yeah the thing
in and of itself is the issue right
but what's more of an issue is the fact
that
you've developed a lifestyle
in which it accommodates that
in which you do this
or whether it be every day whether it be
periodically you do this and and your
lifestyle accommodates that it makes
room for it so if you try to remove it
but you don't change anything else
well we're creatures of behavior so if
we are functioning off a pattern of
behavior you remove one little piece of
this pattern of behavior your body
feels off your body is going to feel
like yo there's something missing
and will inevitably lead you back to
doing the thing that you removed in
order for
you to go back to this normal pattern of
behavior it's like
kind of like how our hormone levels work
in terms of homeostasis
so if you want to get rid of this it's
really just changing your entire
lifestyle changing your day-to-day
habits your day-to-day routine
and you'll see it's actually a lot
easier for you to get rid of
the thing that you're trying to get rid
of because
now instead of your body thinking oh
there's something off your body is more
so like yo there's so much going on we
need to adapt
and i mean that's that's how you make
those lasting changes to be honest with
you um
okay if that's what's in up the hand uh
when you use your hand to please
yourself bro
yeah
okay mariam asks what do y'all think
about celebrating the new year
sister maryam good question indeed
harami do you have any incidents
uh to be honest i know that there's both
opinions that one say it's haram because
it's kind of like it's a celebration and
it's on islamic and since everyone's
doing it it would be haram because it's
kind of like a community thing others
say that it's not community thing it's a
private thing and that means it's halal
you can do what you want and just kind
of be grateful for the new year and the
previous year and all that
i personally am not going to celebrate
it because honestly i just genuinely
don't care for it i think it's an excuse
for people to party like every other
holiday that exists especially christmas
um so for that reason i won't be
celebrating personally but i don't hold
an opinion as to haram or halal i
haven't really looked into
it if you're going to celebrate it you
better be celebrating that with that you
pray at the moment it is 12. that's all
i got to say
but he has ever considered studying in
medina uni or someone like that all the
time bro all the time
i have yeah i have for a bit
inshallah
good question
okay so i actually asked um a lot of
brothers involved in dawah this question
and they said get yourself financially
set
he actually does look at curls
that's actually very important
but um back to the question quickly
um yeah so they said get yourself
financially set so even if it means that
you study like whatever you're gonna say
kinesiology or whatever you're gonna
study for four years however long it
takes do that and then once you're done
and you're able to support your family
um take islamic studies seriously now
when i say that i mean that in the past
four years you don't just stop
learning you do learn it's just not as
much as you would when you take it full
time
that's my opinion
yeah and you can make money doing
anything already
so learn how to make money online and
then once you have that figured out
then go more you know all in with the
islamic studies
[Music]
three muslims gave me so much input to
improve islamically had even a coaching
session with angel it was amazing
[Music]
coaching
is definitely on top tier
sister samira what about making new
year's resolution
um you can make that no you don't you
don't need the new year to make that
yeah
i don't know be honest um
i don't want to say it's imitating
but
if new year's
is
uh uh um i guess on islamic or majority
non-muslim celebration
uh like the community like uh rami was
saying then you taking part in those
things would kind of be like the
equivalent of making a wish and blowing
a candle on a cake on her birthday
what a love welcome
yeah a lot
if you want to do something in life and
improve do it don't wait for the
freaking stupid new years to comfort to
say that i'm gonna just bro just do it
the whole point of striving for you know
perfection and being the best is that
you just do it when it arises you don't
wait to a day or time yeah
there's no there's really no point to
wait till the new year like
if you really think about it like a new
year's resolution new year's celebration
uh staying up until midnight and then
once the clock is this is all cool far
yeah yeah it really is like and i'm not
saying i'm not the one giving a [ __ ] to
what i'm not giving a ruling because i
may do it in this matter but
it's just common sense like if you want
to change your life you do it right now
you don't wait until
uh x amount of time or or x day or x
month or next year or something like
that yeah yeah and bro can you imagine
like there's something about your spouse
that you don't like and you tell them to
fix it and they're like okay yeah once
the new year's comes i'll make a
resolution and be better next year can
you imagine that bro
i don't i don't want to call the [ __ ]
card bro but it kind of is
you relying on a specific day more than
allah or thinking that the timing
matters that much you know i'm not
saying it's [ __ ] but it's it's [ __ ] here
for sure
you know
it's over five do you want to go to the
gym today
i'll be i'm done bro but all the gems
near me are closed including them in a
gym
king's entertainment how many wives do
you desire
i
only desire
bro motivation to stay consistent when
the gyms are closed uh get a pull-up bar
get some resistant bands
maybe a dumbbell or two that's it bro
just move them bro doing something every
day is better than doing nothing yeah
calisthenics
i'm gonna take your fitness to the next
level you go to fivefit.com or on hell
with twoways.com
you already know
small advice for new muslims i don't
really see the advice but
alhamdulillah may allah bless you i
think i think you put it after
yeah i can't see it bro i'm like
scrolling there
okay
question why can't people already marry
someone
they want to be with
um
why what do you mean there's no ruling
against marrying someone you want to be
with maybe maybe it's more like an
emotional all-cap statement like they
want to marry but they're unable to
oh i see when we all know that
all of that is the decree is in the
hands of allah alone
yeah
this is the thing marriage is supposed
to be made easy
mary supposed to be one of the easiest
things like someone they like you go to
the father families talk okay you get
the daughter's hand in marriage
this could happen in the span of a week
it could happen in the span of a year
however long uh you want to take but
even the prophet said don't prolong it
unnecessarily it's supposed to be
something easy and process them himself
said that the best
the best marriage is the one that is
simple
but unfortunately have many people
nowadays in many cultures nowadays that
make it very impossible to get married
notice i said impossible not difficult
because for some people at the age of
like maybe 18 it's basically impossible
for them to get married unless they're
very fortunate
for them but you have people that are
like you know
you need a 50 000
you need a
huge house and two cars and you need to
be a doctor and a lawyer and an
astronaut and you need a 200 000
uh wedding in this big hall you have to
invite a thousand people that you only
know maybe two percent uh of them and
all this stuff
that's why it's so hard nowadays man
i think he was
i think the the brother was uh trying to
respond to someone in the comments
yeah
but may may allah accept but that's
actually a common question and i mean
like a lot of people wonder i want to
get married to this person why doesn't
work out
you know so yeah it's not always going
to work out you might like the thing
which is that for you might not like a
thing which is good for you right
okay next question back from silver and
how to start eating more so i want to
break this down simply for you bro and
to anyone watching that needs to eat
more or be in a caloric surplus which is
means you're eating more calories than
you need to maintain weight so you can
put on some weight whether that be just
bulking up or just maybe doing a lean
bulk and gaining just muscle um don't
think you got to eat more food like
volume of food necessarily
you gotta eat more calories and there's
a thing of volume density i don't want
to spend too much time on this or sorry
calorie density i want to keep it simple
but basically if you have i'm going to
ask both of your questions
if you have a plate of lettuce or let's
say vegetables or a plate of like
chocolate which one has more calories
chocolate of course but which one has
more volume wait for a second yeah which
one has more volume
they both have they're both plate
okay so so in your spa in your plate in
your stomach they occupy the same space
you get what i mean so it'll fill you up
the same i know over time you'll get
hungry faster but my point is it's
easier to eat um both of them right they
both take the same calories or sorry
same volume when you look at the
chocolate you're getting hundreds of
more calories compared to the the
vegetables
so my point is you got to eat smart you
got to eat calorie dense foods foods
that are high in fat and you know could
necessarily be good fats it could be
healthy food too um but foods that are
calorie dense they'll take the same
space as something that's not calorie
dense um or aside they'll take the same
volume but they'll give you way more
calories
so there's there's ways to sneak in
calories so for example if you're making
a sandwich mayonnaise or butter they
both have like 100 calories per spoon
so if you want to take your bread and
you want to put some you know mayo on it
or put some butter on it you're getting
100 calories each serving you do that's
two toes three toasts you're getting 300
calories you're doing a salad you want
to drizzle some extra virgin olive oil
on top maybe like a spoon you get extra
100 calories it's the same volume of
food that's what i'm trying to train you
guys to understand but you're getting
way more calories
and you gotta you really gotta ask
yourself the question why are you gonna
eat more
you know like yeah you're gonna bark
what's your intention behind it
is it ego driven
is there
is there a way that you can make this or
it's like okay something proper you can
do it for the sake of a lot or is it
just to fulfill yourself are you just
trying to get more muscle to you know
okay satisfy your ego stroke your ego
you really gotta ask yourself this
because
i see too many people go down this road
you know i was one of them
so i can directly speak on this
and i believe
correct me if i'm wrong but it's
it's actually not a good thing
in islam spiritually to overeat
you know when you overeat it's it's kind
of like uh it's like a sin isn't it
yeah the prophet
said one of the worst vessels to fill
is the stomach
yeah so if you are going to be doing
this whole thing of eating more and you
have a proper intention
understand you don't need to eat that
much more you just got to find how much
calories is like your maintenance with
the amount of activity that you're doing
and then you add like maybe 100 to 200
calories extra which is not much at all
and if you do
the uh low volume but very nutrient
dense foods like what fire was talking
about
you can technically eat more
but still not overfill your uh your
stomach yeah that's that's what i was
getting to you can eat less but get more
calories you know what i mean
so
unhard he knows
brother-in-law right stop with the last
of 2021 and the three the new year's
resolutions news i don't know where we
wrote that bro i wrote down last q a of
2021 right 2021 is the gregorian
calendar year that we're currently in
and this is the last video that we'll
make
i don't know what's so like simple bro
all right next questions
i'm pretty sure bro
if if they were all right
if they weren't happy i love you bro
all right
i don't know what do you think bro
inshallah
inshallah i know the brother personally
but um
these guys want stuff going on right now
so
inshallah we can get him on
good
here
just
past i think he was talking about
how do you think it will take
for the world to turn cashless
and move online my guess is 2030 because
of ronald
that's that's tough bro you got a super
chat
i really don't know though
exactly for the supporting the channel
about the prayer at home because fear of
the
hammock
or not 22 what where is that from i
think it's norwegian
if i'm correct
it could be wrong
so um
praying friday jeremiah at home i don't
believe is allowed in any method in
islam specifically in the field of imam
shafi rahim allah
the math of of imam shafiq
says that
there are basically three conditions for
a gym right to be a drummer a one is
that it needs to be i think more than
three people a group of people
uh two it has to be in a place that's
like a huge place of congregation that
everyone knows that this is the place
and um the third one i can't remember
the third one exactly but my point is
that that rule that it has to be a
well-known place that's out of public
and like everyone can attend it there as
a group
that doesn't happen in your house unless
you make your house that place
um so it's completely haram as far as i
know and it would not be accepted um
even if you like
put on like a live stream broadcast of
someone praying jumera and giving a
khutba and all of that stuff
i don't think it would be accepted as
far as i know
for the question once again
very good question a lot of people might
benefit inshallah
brother-in-law writes they're not
scholars yeah bro um no pretty obvious
brother we're not scholars you don't see
chef ramirez
or anything like that
this is
[Music]
[Music]
are you from london
i wish they i wish they gave a little
message with their question or something
yeah
all right question from sahana let's go
with it how to start planning for a
madonna in events
what
i i didn't think
you don't plan for ramadan do you maybe
mentally or spiritually
oh i guess
i guess it'd be nice to
you know start like detoxing
from food you know maybe doing some like
fasting periodically
and kind of disconnecting from
electronics slowly
so that once ramadan comes it's like
you know
you're in it if you know what i mean
[Music]
i got a question from sister samira i
know you guys are brothers what tips
advice do you guys have for a sister who
wants to lose more weight and it sounds
healthy or prettier naturally um i'll
say two things real quick to keep it
just simple and broad um and i'll let on
how and rami elaborate on that if they
do wish to
but number one you gotta go on a caloric
deficit right which means you must be
burning more calories than you're
consuming so you could do this through
moving a little more so doing a little
more physical activity or you could do
it through number two which is eating a
little less
i recommend combining it so you don't
have to work out too much more and you
don't have to eat less too much so it's
kind of like you eat a little less and
you work out a little more
yeah
i would agree i would agree actually
i would say that it really just boils
down to calories and calories out
you know
and if you
if you pay attention to the foods you
eat and instead of trying to like cut
everything out
you just eat more of the foods that are
filling that are more voluminous
and then you can add in like a few of
the foods that you really enjoy
this will make it very easy for you to
have a calorie deficit but still be
enjoying yourself at the same time
um
[Music]
um
first thing i want to say is
you need to do your research and consult
a scholar
and come to your own conclusion
uh after
proper consultation with scholars in sri
lanka and all that if it's permissible
okay
we follow
the
idea that cryptocurrency is permissible
however
not all cryptocurrencies not all coins
so i just want to make that clear
um also when it comes to how do we
invest we made an episode which
tucker um you can write the three
muslims bitcoin on youtube search bar
find that episode it's a good episode
mashallah the brother is a graduate from
the islamic university of medina in
finance islamic finance
and he's big on bitcoin so there we talk
about actual practical strategies on how
to invest your money so if you have this
much money should you invest it all at
once should you dollar cost average
stuff like that in terms of like how to
practically put the money in there's
different apps so coinbase binance
crypto.com make sure whatever app you
use it's it's regulated where you're at
for example i know finance was set
through closed in a part of canada where
we live but now they're they're not
going to close right so and i think in
the u.s finance is not there it's not
operating
so just be careful of that
i got this
[Music]
a good question for you
accepting of lukewarm muslims haven't we
learned from our mistake from the
mistaken christians that's good question
um it's because this is something that
is culturally being spread that um
well actually basically it starts at
secularism we live in secularist
countries which means that you divide
church and state which means that islam
is not the option it's it's just another
option you can be muslim you can be
christian you can be whatever it's it's
whatever and they skip over the ayah in
the quran where allah says the only deen
with allah is islam and that he revealed
islam as a deen to triumph all over
every other deen
these muslims lukewarm muslims as you
call them they tend to just kind of skip
over this verse skim over it or you know
close their eyes when they're reading it
um which is very oxymoronic
but in islam we are taught that islam is
the way the only way but the problem is
living in the secular society teaching
that islam is just another way they've
boiled it down to only the spiritual
parts
which is basically what the christians
do as you mentioned you know we just we
just pray and we fast and we stick to
ourselves we read our quran in our the
corner of our home and in khalasith
that's not what islam is islam is what
allah says he made us a middle nation
that's what the um is supposed to be a
middle nation so we do have the
spirituality and all of that but we also
have the physical actions the learning
the knowledge the teaching uh in the
dawah
and we're taught to teach even if it's
just one verse but unfortunately this is
not something the scholars are teaching
the muslims and honestly that's a it's a
huge failure i would say on a lot of the
speakers and a lot of the scholars that
they don't propagate the proper
understanding of islam that it's not
just spiritual
bro being lukewarm is a result of an
individual it's not a result of a
religion
because in christianity in the bible it
says
to not be lukewarm it says you're either
hot or cold and if you look warm i'm
gonna spit you out
we got six minutes left or five minutes
left so guys if you have any questions
we got two questions now for another i
know it's the cut in five minutes so do
send a super chat if you really want
your important questions answered but i
know for the sake of time let's be quick
with it first question uh any experience
with brothers and sisters dealing with
depression have you experienced
something similar
there's a
further away you get from allah
the more you're going to be depressed
just think about this all right
depression anxiety anger frustration
all this stuff
it stems from you trying to be in
control you trying to play god
essentially
like if you get angry because something
happened you're getting angry because it
didn't go the way you planned or the way
you were expecting it to
but if you were if you accepted it and
you said you know it's the cut of allah
allah is going to do however
he's going to do
if it happens then it's not the way that
you want it to happen well
it's the color of allah you accept it
for what it is
as if you're depressed
you are
essentially you know like they say
you're living in the past but you're
depressed because
something didn't go exactly how you
wanted to or right now in the present
day is not exactly how you want it to be
or maybe something that's gonna happen
might not be exactly how you want it to
be you know and when it comes to like
depression to where it has no real
reason
you just i don't know where to press oh
that's different that's like
that's like a hormonal type thing
uh maybe nutrient deficiency or
sleep issues stuff like that you know i
agree big shout out to allah for
becoming a member welcome to the family
next one for anna from sister samira uh
by the way this is gonna depend on if
ana wants to answer this or not right um
the question is for anna was it hard to
give up on things like okay those two i
don't know if uh
if he even wants to talk about it if he
even has any experience or if he gave
that up before i became muslim
but i think it's going to vary between
person and person was it hard bro a
river river to river
um now for me i was already like
weaning away from that stuff like i'd
say more than
a year before becoming almost i'm like
yeah i did it
randomly blue moons if i was with
friends but even then like after i would
do i'd be like yeah
i regret doing that
so it was like it was already something
that i was like you know kicking out
hmm
hit the face during war or for
self-defense we're not scholars so
there's not a fatwa but my understanding
is when it's life and death like when
you're protecting your family when you
know it
push comes to shove nothing is off the
table
yeah
yeah striking your brother's face
like for no reason when you know that's
that's not it
yeah one thing i want to add is if it's
war like let's say like you i mean i'm
not going to use any volatility if it's
a war you're not allowed to like like
kind of
ruin the face of like the the dead
basically like if they're already done
you're angry you can't like take it out
on their dead face basically
but and
you know allah
maybe in war
you can you can strike the face maybe in
a fight you can strike the face but
not even trying to be idealistic here
just being realistic all right if you
could do so without striking the face
not only does that show that your skill
level is way way higher than the person
that you are engaging with but it also
shows like
you're taking what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said very
seriously and
again that's your intention allah knows
your intention better than anyone so
just something to throw in there
all right thoughts on women training
with men in bjj
they better be your husband yeah i was
gonna say that i was gonna say honestly
even though training is very very
important and my
my teacher even says it's
meaning it's actually obligatory on the
whole community because we all need to
know how to defend ourselves as muslims
that's his opinion may allah and
honestly i'm
not required but i'm leaning towards
that opinion as well because it is very
important although it's important
that it doesn't mean that you
justify
this
sin with that so we have
makassar sharia we have objectives of
the sharia things that sharia came to
protect which one is our honor our
dignity our protection our safety all
that but you cannot use the makasid the
objectives of the sharia as something we
call an illa as a basis
of
basically deriving a ruling you can't
say since islam teaches us to defend
ourselves
it's now halal to learn to train and or
to learn to fight by training with men
you can't do that allah has made it very
clear that any contact with the not with
the opposite gender who's non-mushram is
100 haram regardless of the circumstance
now if this was an absolute necessity
maybe that would be different
but you can train with your mahram men
which they should be learning how to
fight 100
um or if they're not willing to then
there are sisters as well that can train
you in shock
all right so we're basically the time to
just rapid fire answer this one quick
thing that y'all learned this year
uh i learned
or re
reaffirmed my my belief that one year is
all it takes to change your life bro
what about you
i learned honestly i learned a lot
i can't really boil it down to one just
it's it's amazing 100 percent
yeah i learned a lot
i can't really i can't really boil that
down
that's kevin from ireland we did an
episode with him
oh no as a new reverb bro
could you address holmes question
baby steps boy
baby steps
take a little by little
just learn at your own pace
um but do learn don't prolong it for no
reason
was it hard to upload consistently no
bro we're a team
so every horses you know everything's
easy uh together and alhamdulillah one
year is done and we did it and we're
going to keep going inshaallah
i think she's saying that she's training
with her husband masha allah that's
amazing i love
so we got one member question from
today's new member aloha
okay
have you seen commonwealth's channel by
brother sheed where i made a video
pushing back on fire's comment yeah so
you know i'm not gonna address that
brother gabriel commented on that uh on
the video on behalf of all of us it was
a very good comment um he was talking
about the academic dishonesty so we see
that a lot of channels they take
snippets of what we say and they take it
out of context so they take like five
seconds of something from an hour-long
lecture and they formulate their own
opinions um i'm not gonna speak on that
but what i do know is in that video we
were talking about uh value of men and
women when it comes to marriage not in
the eyes of allah and
it's something that's very easily taken
out of context
yet i'm still trying to meet him so i
can
dunk on him and break his ankle
inshallah we'll see we'll see
what was that thing that she has saw or
he is that
what is that
zoe zoja i think it's like part with
like what what eve was to adam
i think
inshallah i know that zigzag is going
good i think we have a tick tock on the
left from that we posted this week
uh we have a sister helping us with that
channel and that's our most viewed video
which is crazy so if you guys aren't on
uh on a tick tock follow us at the three
muslims
okay on our rights i had to stop muay
thai training before i became muslim
i've been wondering if you guys knew any
women instructor who teach to women
online i'm sure there's tons on fiverr
the thing is online training is never
gonna be the same as
in person training so i would highly
suggest looking for a female
trainer of muay thai
in your area and if that's not possible
um
i forgot to say this before but
a woman can spar with her brother like
not like brother in faith but like her
blood brother correct
i'm not sure
like like train with them like brazilian
jiu jitsu with her blood brother uh yeah
as far as i know i don't i don't think
it's a problem i'm not a scholar
oh i'm not sure if you did but maybe
that might give you a better answer
but
what's the one i know
bro online is not april
yeah it's not
tips on time management
figure out what you need to do
figure out a routine for yourself that
can accommodate these things that you
need to do
and then just stick to that routine as
simple as that then you don't have to be
trying to time manage every little thing
every single day
it just kind of it's already worked out
in advance
find the episode we made on productivity
i think honorable has to go right now
all right it's 105.
from the love bro
it is
allah
time y'all
as well
won't stick around too much longer
either um what i will say is there's a
there's a video
where we wrote uh where we talked about
productivity so search up the three
muslims productivity if i remember
correctly it's episode 28 but it might
not be it might not even be close but
it's probably somewhere around that um
and we we we went in bro there's gems
and a lot of wisdom on actual practical
things you can do um that we talked
about inshallah
can you have a pitbull dog dogs are
permissible if they're for the sake of
um protection
and i know there's there's you know
specific rulings on that too there's
nuances i believe keeping just pets like
dogs in the house just because you want
a pet i don't that's i don't think
that's permissible in islam whatsoever
because the saliva is impure
um adhering to the sunnah diet i didn't
know there was such thing as a sunnah
diet to be honest
um
i believe there's some of that like uh
just following the the
etiquettes of eating from the prophet
saws
so you know
you know not eating as much not feeling
your stomach as much that's like the
first party if you can't do that then
follow the you know one third food one
third water one third day yeah yeah i
mean if you can't
kind of fill yourself three times in a
day then eat half of what you would in
one meal six times you know what i mean
that way technically you're not full
at any point
brother zade how should i convince my
parents to get a cat um bro i'mma tell
you the exact same thing that happened
to me and my mom and dad may allah bless
them i love them for the sake of allah
and they watch our podcast too so i'm
dead if you're watching this you know
this is true i wanted to get a cat all
my life my parents said no um not
because haram or anything just you know
there's fur which is very annoying so
their reasons were very justified and
they were against that so
bro when i moved up first thing i did
was get a cat believe that
if if you didn't get that so my advice
is bro
just get your own spot
you shouldn't have to convince
your parents to get a cat you can if it
doesn't work it's still their place so
you gotta respect that
you know
yeah
you have to make it a super chat bro i
don't know where they're at to be honest
but i have um
i only i only have these ones
unfortunately i don't have my uh my
shades on me so you get like not the
cool ramen but like the nerdy looking
rami
i hope this
makes up for it
if not i'll send you a picture bro
but um
where is jorge
oh man he's at drama and we're gonna go
to the gym
it's not haram to trim your beard um
actually
what we will say and rami sent me a
beautiful video bro
for that video it's from sheikh uthman
even farooq on the rulings and
etiquettes of trimming the beard i
highly recommend all of the brothers
watch that video it will be very
beneficial inshallah
insha allah allah
um
there is a video asking about
rationality
a video
uh just a video i'm going to comment
sorry
rationality yeah i think it is let me
see
this one
just commented again actually oh let me
see
it just seems interesting
yeah
so how was it that we use rationality to
purple islam but can't use rationality
to criticize some aspects of it what if
there is any part of islam that is
irrational
then it can be rationally critiqued 100
percent but there is no part of islam
that is that's irrational because what
is what is rationality rationality is
looking at the world and basically
understanding facts about it
and
basically knowing that it works in a
cohesive manner you rationalities
essentially look at the world and you
have premises
that um you know are true so something
an example of something that's
irrational
is um
something that's irrational would be
like
uh
i have parts a car has parts therefore
like i'm i'm basically like a car
in one way yeah but it's irrational to
say something like that that's what
rationality is so since islam is
perfectly
sound in terms of the fitra in the mind
and the reality of the world there's
nothing you can look and say that's
irrational people will make moral
arguments
like oh you why do you guys have like
stoning and
chopping hands and all this stuff
um that's a moral
argument it's subjective it's not
irrational and in any way to be
completely honest
so i hope the answer answers inshallah
yo so i think
it's like i'm just texting my boy who's
gonna pick me up for drama uh
because it's been about a year right and
this is the last podcast of 2021
do you think we should bro rami me and
you
i would have to run upstairs and get get
him i can
let's do it bro i'll do it if you do it
all right i'll be back all right guys
stay tuned for the cattle's coming up
i'm gonna show you
no no
no no no
okay
it's okay
okay
it's okay
oh it's okay
it's okay
he's uh he's a little cuckoo right now
he's a little crazy right now
he's nervous oh it's okay it's okay
it's okay baby
oh
okay he ran he's gone
i have fur all over me
she's so cute
i cannot i think you're muted i can't
hear you
can bring the other one she's meowing at
the door right now
okay i'm gonna grab her
welcome
oh
hi princess
wow yours is so calm both of my cats are
like
frantic and panicky
oh my god
princess it's okay princess
i'm gonna try and turn
oh there she is
hi princess
it's okay
it's okay baby
there she is
okay good girl
all right
we have to go to uh or at least i have
to go to drumroll yeah
all right guys
let's put this cap down
all right that's enough there's enough
cats uh so rami do you want to tell
people what your cat's named
uh the one you just saw the little
fluffy one her name's princess and the
one before
her is
uh
you want to tell them my cat's name bro
his cat's name is
zara
zoro with the zed
mashaallah
male or female uh zara is a female
princess is female or mocha is a male
okay type i really have to go yeah same
here all right guys
until next week
[Music]
again